bonjour à tous je vous retrouve en cette
veille de noël avec quelques petits
messages à partager je suis rongé par la
tristesse une certaine neurasthénie
s'est emparée de moi et tous les jours
je pleure
j'ai alors la vigilance c'est évidemment
de continuer à voir nos gestes barrières
donc moi je sais par de faire des
spectacles je sais faire des scénarii
écrire bon
j'ai pas entendu vous savez faire dit je
sais faire des spectacles le pluriel de
scénario c'est quoi
je fais des scénarii vous êtes sûr de
votre coup la police est arrivée
oui donc je ne me supporte plus je sens
mon corps et mon esprit se
recroqueviller sur eux mêmes et la seule
chose dont j'ai envie c'est de partir
voilà le message que je voulais vous
passez en vous souhaitant de très bonnes
fêtes en vous souhaitant un joyeux noël
en famille avec vos proches
[Musique]